[Musik]
und heller der klima opfer ich wollte
mir eigentlich super wie zu überlegen
für euch aber dann hatte ich doch keinen
bock oder wie man heute sagt eine
handlungs lücke da haben die kollegen
eine handlungs lücke und zwar zwischen
unsern wenn es von deutschland seine
klimaziele aufgibt wie soll man dann
noch andere überzeugen arme
entwicklungsländer oder diktaturen wie
die usa wie sollen wir bürger das ganze
klima terium noch ernst nehmen ab sofort
verbiete ich der merkel überhaupt noch
das wort klima in den mund zu nehmen
diese ekelhaften sonntagsreden
wir brauchen dieses pariser abkommen um
unsere schöpfung zu bewahren
der ist dumm gebabbelt kannst dir sparen
[Musik]
tempo sie mit strom aus kohle palme
grünwald an den polen der hosenanzug
schwätzt vom klima da wird mein
brechreiz immer schlimmer und für alle
steigen
in bangladesch egal ist das potsdamer
institut für klimaforschung warnt jetzt
vor immer mehr hochwasser in deutschland
die keller nassen winter auf der chip in
deutschland keine sau volt weg sind für
gini vibrieren
das verspreche ich ihnen danken ich hab
das land ich schaffe es leise der
deutsche klimaschutz ist scheiße
[Musik]